これが一枚の紙です。もし私がそれをくしゃくしゃに
して病院の窓から投げ出すと
、私は叱られるでしょう。
彼らが
窓からそれを投げたことであなたを称賛する唯一の場所は
おそらくこの精神病棟
でしょう。 氏と言う
今日は元気だったので、ショットして寝る時間だった
ので、40年ほど
前に病気になり、病院にチェックインしなければならなかった
ので、周りに紙しかなかったので
、紙以外に何もできませんでし
た。
少し怒りを覚え
、病院の窓の外に紙を
持って行ったら、看護師が来て、病院の庭にゴミを投げ込まないようにと言った
ので、病院の庭を見たの
かもしれません。
病院の敷地の外に投げるだけで大丈夫なので
、彼女が言ったことを解釈したのです
。私は自分がしなければならないことを考えました。私は紙の
飛行機を作ら
なければなりません。
一枚の紙が出た
ので、何度も試行錯誤を繰り返し
た結果、紙の飛行機を作る
ことができ、それを飛ばして
病院の庭を横切り、病院の
敷地外に着陸することができました。
私に腹を立てたが、私はそれをやり続けた
完璧なものでしたかったのですが、
ようやく外に出て唾を吐くようなものができたのですが
、もちろん地元の
人からも不満があり
、通常より早く退院できたのかもしれません。
もっと適切な言い方をすれば
、大学に行って卒業したいのです
が、基本的に
は健康上の理由で大変だった
ので、基本的には
アパートで寝ているだけだったので、
毎日 天井を見るだけで、天井
の線や質感のよう
に見え
て、まるで宇宙の
ようで、天の川のように見えたので、笑ってしまうかもしれ
ませんが、と思い
ました。 宇宙から地球に向かって紙飛行機を見つけられたら、
変だ
と
思うかもしれませんが、燃えると思うかもしれませんが、燃えないかもしれないと思ったのですが、
燃えないとき それは入ってくる
突然大気圏
に入ると
突然冷気に入るのではなく、ゆっくりでは
なくゆっくりと気温が変化している
ので、紙切れになるかも
しれません。
そこに休憩があれば、燃え
ない紙が
あればいいので
、紙の飛行機を作れ
たら、大気中に出して
燃えないかもしれません。 だから私は1,000回以上
の異なる紙の飛行機
を作りました私は目を覚ましてから紙の飛行機
を眠りに戻します目を覚ます紙の
飛行機
を作ります私は1,500以上の異なる種類の
紙の飛行機を作りましたそして最後に私
は何をする必要があるかを理解しました そして
、このスペースシャトルタイプ
の紙の飛行機を作ることができました。ここで作りましょう。
あなたの前に作りたい
ので、紙の飛行機
です。折りたたむ必要があるので、はさみもはさみも使用しません。
一枚の紙で
折りたたむ
だけで少し蹴る必要がありますが、3Dに
なります。このような形になっている
ので、
すぐに試してみて、頭に着地するようにします。
保険があるので、  go song
3 2 1
多分100点満点中
70点最後まで行けると思っていたのですが、多分
100点満点中70点が得点なので、一
枚の紙でいろいろな
紙飛行機を作って健康になりました
良くなりましたそして私はしばしば
人々にこれを行う方法を教えますそして彼らは言いますそして私
は
あなたがナンバーワンになりたいと彼らが言った紙の飛行機が好きだと人々に話します
私はナンバーワンになりたいのです
が、
世界一になるとは言わなかったので
、紙飛行機に関しては世界一になると
言ったのですが、どうすればいいのでしょうか。
紙の飛行機に関してはナンバーワンであり、
私は実際にこれらのJに関する
何かについて言及したことを忘れていることに気づきました
AXAは実際に
これを宇宙で打ち上げることができるという承認を得ました、
そして私たちがしなければならないのは
それをするのに35年かそこらかかっただけです
そして次は来月NASAに行きます
そして私たちは行きます 宇宙
から打ち上げることができるように承認を得るために報告することで
あり、私
はそれを国のシャッター
に乗せることができるようにしたいので、宇宙からそれを見ることができるようにシャトルします。
次に、
前の議論に戻って、どう
すれば世界でナンバーワンになることができるのか、世界でナンバーワンになる必要はないのですが、もし私
がナンバーワンになりたいと
思ったら、どうすればこれを実際に行うことができるのか、実際には
忘れていました
前回の紙の飛行機で話したことも忘れてしまいました
が、マハセブンには
風洞テストがあり、それをテストして
風洞テストに入れました。
マッチ7を維持することができ、実際には多くの
異なる雑誌で 世界中
で
3月7日のウィンドトンネルテストを維持できたので
、ナンバーワンになる
にはギネス記録を作成する
必要があると思います。さまざまなことを行う必要がありますが、私は
ギネスブックの記録は
27秒6秒だったのですが、
それは久しぶりだと思うかもしれ
ませんが、実際には10回以上できるとしたら
通常、紙の
飛行機の競技では数秒程度が勝ちますが、
10秒はかなり長く、実際に20秒間それを行うこと
ができるのは世界で2人だけ
です。
そのうちの1人は25秒ですが、
実際には肩を痛めているので、彼はできません。
紙の飛行機での長距離飛行
は世界記録の27秒6秒なので、
これが本当に可能かどうか本当に疑問に
思ったので、
最長の記録は19秒でし
た。 私が82キロの時にできることは3つあり
ます。体重を減らす必要があると思ったので、
重すぎる場合は遠くに投げることができません。
紙の飛行機も研究してください。
同じ紙になりたいです。
翼を広くすることはできますが、幅を
広くしすぎる
と、強度が失われるわけで
はないので、高くすることはできません。
そのため、必要な
紙を高くすることができます。
丈夫な紙と
投げ方も考えているので、例
え
ば行くといつもホテルに行ってティ
ッシュペーパーをやるなど気をつけないといけないので
、投げてみたら
日本の武道
と同じように、通常の武道と同じように立っていなければならない
ので、右足が前に出て
、たとえば剣道
もそうです。
あなたは上を目指してそれを
投げ
ますがここではあなたのb 年をとる
と痛くなるので
、ギネス世界記録を破って会うことができたの
かもしれませんが、ビデオを見せることができるかもしれません。
紙飛行機の
ことを子供たちに教えていた私はネパールの子供たちにこれについて教えたいと思っていました
年ほど前
にネパールに行きました。
それから高山から
紙飛行機を飛ばしたいのです
が、この写真の前の写真でわかるように、
私
は銃を持った兵士に囲まれ、彼ら
は私に銃を向けました。
当時、
ネパールは内戦の真っ最中だったので、紙飛行機にしたかった
ので、実はそこに反政府
軍の基地があったのですが、知らなかったので
、その地域に行って
みました。 おそらく
殺されたでしょう 考えて、私
は紙の飛行機を飛ばしたいと言ったので、
私は来ました、そして彼らはおそらく
彼らを殺すために私たちが何をすべきかを言っていました、または
それは彼らが
話していたようですが、私は実際にこの紙を見て待つと言いました
紙を投げて、実際に撮った写真
です。
うまく飛べなかったらどうなるのかと思ってい
たので、揺れていたのですが
、飛べたので、実は
よく考えました。
兵士を私の側に連れて行くことができるように、私
はあなたも紙の飛行機
を飛ばしてみませんか、それであなたもそれを飛ばして、
みんなが紙の飛行機を飛ばすのを見ているので
、これは次の
飛行機です。
これで戦争を終わらせることができれば
素晴らしいと思います。この作品は素晴らしいと思っていたので
、この写真を見るだけで、紙の
飛行機は実際には平和のしるしであるという印象を見ることができます。
みなさんも紙飛行機を作ってくださいと思います
レーンは外に出て飛んで楽しん
でくれてありがとう